Hi, Nick, how are you?
I am very well, thank you.
How are you doing?
You look fantastic.
Well, that's very generous.
I'll pass that right back at you.
Oh, thank you.
The pandemic has been good to you.
You look stunning.
And the last time we saw each other was also a party.
It was a long time ago, yeah, Megan and I
came to a party at your house in the Hollywood Hills.
And it was the only time in my life
I've been to an actual Toga party.
I am not kidding.
As Nick attests, I am that guy.
I threw a major like 500 person
animal house style Toga party.
And you were with your wife.
Megan Mullally is a goddess.
I love her as Karen, obviously on Will and Grace.
She changed the course of all of our lives
and embodied a character that became so famous and iconic
which is such a, not easy feat for an actor to do.
Absolutely, and imagine what a lucky donkey
you would feel like if every morning you wake up
and she's laying there next to you, it's pretty crazy.
And how did you woo this goddess?
We met doing a play 21 years ago
and I invited her on a date.
I left her a message
and turned out it was a bit of a dirty trick.
The phone number that she had,
and this used to be a thing,
when you had to like especially for women
that might be harassed by people.
You would give a fake number.
So on the cast list, she put her fax number.
And so it turned out that I had left a message
on her fax machine.
And a couple of weeks later,
she saw the light blinking on her fax machine
and listened to it.
And so it scored me some points
and it also scored me some guilt points.
Cause then she felt bad
and she had to actually go out to dinner with me
to make it up to me.
And then the rest is history.
And here we are on the Drew Barrymore show.
(audience laughs)
And that's not the only time
that you kind of went for it.
Didn't a post-it help you land another job as well?
Yes, I was auditioning for a part on The Office
and the creator of Parks and Rec was a writer on The Office.
And I was auditioning for him and he really liked me
and he wanted to cast me in the part, but I couldn't do it.
So he wrote my name on a post-it
and put it on his computer monitor
to remind himself three years later when they said,
"Hey Greg Daniels said, we want to do a show together,"
which became Parks and Recreation.
He said, "Ah-hah, I have this post-it.
I want this guy Nick Offerman on the show."
And it ended up working out thankfully.
And for my wrap gift, he found the post-it
and he had it framed and gave it to me.
We have a picture of it.
I went in to read for Poltergeist
and I didn't get the part
but I got to come back for ET and that's that.
Timing is everything.
Sometimes it's a better thing
that something didn't work out.
And it's great that you have evidence of that.
And by the way, even your first gig
in like 1996 was a little unorthodox.
You were on a Nickelodeon show called KaBlam!
Will you tell us about that character of yours?
Yeah, I mean midriff shirts
used to be contractual with me.
That was my thing back in the 90s.
My friend Greg Harrison made this show called KaBlam
and he brought me to Los Angeles to play the bad guy.
It was like a live action cartoon.
So it was cartoon acting, even though we were real people
but the sets looked like cartoons.
And it was really fun and crazy
and was an incredible introduction to Hollywood.
I love that, and speaking of animated,
you play a single dad named Beef
on the animated series, The Great North.
I'm so excited about this.
What are we going to get into?
Well, I'm the dad of this family.
The cast is just bananas all-stars.
Aparna Nancherla, Dulce Sloan, Megan Mullally,
Jenny Slate, Will Forte, Paul Rust and on and on.
The guest cast is just crazy.
And so to get to play with all these people
who just make me laugh constantly
in a vessel through which we're just delivering medicine
we're making people laugh,
but it's also really good hearted.
One of my son's is gay.
There's all kinds of social issues being addressed.
So we're subtly trying to help all of us
be more decent through a funny cartoon.
It's like really wholesome messaging with farts.
(audience laughs)
And we need that, comedy is medicine, it just is.
And I live for it.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪